all differences are illusions what is
real is the unbroken seamless plenum of
being and and this is what we need to
learn because our whole social construct
has been based on the establishment and
maintenance of boundaries I mean we are
the most boundary obsessed human society
that has ever existed you know when I go
to the Amazon and spend time with the
upper River people the hardest thing for
me to get used to is that I never have
any privacy ever you know
I hang my hammock in the longhouse and
you know people are fighting and giving
birth and having sex and arguing and
doing all these things and even when you
even the act of defecation is not
necessarily private so boundary
dissolution and boundary maintenance is
what really cares I 'ti about these
things is what characterizes our society
I mean our world is getting uglier and
meaner and more mean-spirited by the
moment because those who have are so
anxious about the fact that they might
be asked to share it I mean what we have
gone through in the last 12 years in
this country is a tremendous transfer of
wealth to the upper 2% of society and
become concomitant ly a tremendous
spread of anxiety alienation and a
dehumanizing of the entire social
enterprise I mean if we don't give hold
of ourselves the next century most of
the world is going to be a toxic desert
and then here and there there will be
very well defended pleasure domes in
which a very small number
incredibly wealthy people will live out
lives of utterly self-indulgent
hedonistic fantasy in denial of the
moral catastrophe that they participated
in in order to achieve that hedonic
state of isolation I mean that's clearly
happening in metaphorically that's what
we have already I mean not to freak you
out but that's where we're sitting right
now you know I mean compared to Bosnia
Haiti and Somalia what we have to do is
teach people to care for each other as a
primary value not something you do after
you know you pay for your Mercedes and
all that but as the primary value we
have to have community it's very simple
we don't have community we have a
free-for-all
where the devil takes the hindmost the
most brutal and ruthless among us rise
to the top and everybody else has a foot
on their neck we we are now in a hell of
a fix because we've waited so long to
address these problems there is not now
enough gold aluminum iron so forth in
the planet to raise everyone to a
middle-class standard as it's enjoyed in
Southern California and yet we have
unleashed these expectations in everyone
by flagellating people with images of
material wealth and comfort
we must really individual and the
quality of individual experience in
other words you have to convince
somebody that you are a richer person on
five grams of psilocybin than you are if
you live in a five million dollar house
and are spending with $50,000 a year on
psychotherapy because you're miss
you see we have allowed ourselves to be
tremendously disempowered by allowing
our values to shift toward the material
domain you can't take it with you folks
but the soul is the vehicle that you do
take with you into whatever dimensions
of continuity exist beyond this mortal
coil so instead of balancing and
replacing the tires on your Porsche you
should be balancing and replacing the
tires on your after death vehicle after
all that's the one that's going to have
to serve you well in the clinches you
see
[Music]